Now that we have an idea about the effect of round-off error,
we can actually compute some estimates.
For the forward Euler method, the total error is composed of two parts--
the part due to the Euler method, the global truncation error, if you remember that term.
A constant times the step size plus the error due to round off,
which seems to be proportionate to the number of steps
and, hence, inversely proportional to the step size
Epsilon denotes the relative size of the error.
It's something like 10⁻⁷ or 10⁻¹⁶.
By which fraction does our number tend to change due to round off?
Again, we should see proportionality here.
If we have twice the amount of error in each step.
We should be seeing twice the amount of total error,
even though, again, the error induced in the earlier steps is growing over time.
D is some proportionality constant that we don't know yet
and that depends on the problem as does C.
So, there is one component to the error that grows from zero to infinity on principle.
There is another component to the error that starts at infinity and decays to zero.
We have to have a minimum in between.
This is what we saw in the experiment.
It's called the step size at that minimum hmin.
It does not make sense to use more steps, that is, to use a smaller step size,
because the error will be growing again due to round-off.
Now, here is a quiz.
For the two types of floating point numbers that we're typically dealing with,
we can specify the value of epsilon.
It's about 10⁻⁷ for single precision.
In C and related languages, that's called float.
It's about 10⁻¹⁶ for double position.
Python works at double position, and the arrays of numpy can be configured
as to which position they should be using.
Now here comes the quiz.
Say we do an experiment at single position
and find that the value of hmin amounts to 10⁻⁴.
If we try to solve the same problem at double position,
what do you expect to be the value of hmin?
Pick one of these: 3 * 10⁻⁹, 4 * 10⁻¹⁰, 5 * 10⁻¹¹?
Here is a hint: at the minimum, it turns out that the contribution of both parts is the same.
Ch will equal Dε/h.